what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally covering Brian
Azzarello as Batman damned or at least
the first part this is actually the
first of a three-issue series I was
talking to Sal overcome a pop and for
what he was telling me this is a direct
sequel to Brian Azzarello Joker which
gives me even more excited if you never
read Brian Azzarello Joker it's a
marriage thing oh my god it's like it's
like one of the best Joker stories ever
told like it's it's pretty badass and
it's pretty solid one of the coolest
things about it is it's actually told
from the perspective of like a low-level
guy about like the mystery and intrigue
surrounding the Joker how crazy he is
and all I kind of good stuff how like
general criminals see him and so on and
so forth and of course it includes the
Joker Batman so on and so forth but what
this does is this initially picks up
with Batman basically beam I picked up
in an ambulance and then literally being
whisked off after falling off a bridge
hence the reason this sequel to the idea
of it being or I guess the idea of it
being the sequel to Brian Azzarello
Stoker
now the cool thing is that we get this
kind of like narration that goes on you
know life and death and and so on
walking into the light whether or not
the light really exists and different
things like that but it's kind of crazy
because while this whole thing goes on
like people are kind of flabbergasted by
the fact that it's the Batman right
because that's one of the things to keep
in mind when it comes to Gotham City
Batman usually doesn't get picked up by
ambulances right like the Batman goes
out he does his own thing if he gets
injured then usually it's like Alfred or
somebody who gets him and takes him back
to Wayne Manor back to the Batcave and
of course he gets whatever treatment he
needs hence the reason why having Alfred
is so beneficial because he's a field
medic but one of the guys goes to
basically like cut off his mask to
remove his mask under the auspices that
well they need to be able to treat him
and then of course he also want to know
what his ideas now of course this leads
to Batman waking up and incapacitating
the guys and he basically just like
lands in the middle of a city street and
is kind of nuts because this goes into
like how the average person views Batman
which is actually really really awesome
and different writers have interpreted
this different ways for example if you
go and you read a Batman war on crime by
Paul Dini and Alex Ross people look to
Batman as something to fear but also as
like a source of hope Batman's only
something to be scared of if you're a
criminal
but if you're a good guy Batman's
looking out for you for in this story
it's really more of like Batman's like
that man's terrifying to everyone
everybody scared a Batman though like
he's a monster that he's dangerous he's
scary that kind of a thing people are
saying stay back and it's actually
pretty awesome because he basically ends
up running into an alleyway and then
collapses next to a building and then in
turn like literally starts to kind of
panic call for Alfred and so on only for
somebody to walk up and he basically
realizes that he's in that it's not
actually Alfred and we enough
the narrator of this whole thing is none
other than John Constantine and that's
awesome because you never usually see
Constantine cross over I mean he does
and he's really like one of the only
members of the magical community that
crosses over with the rest of the DC
Universe but you don't see it happen all
the time and so what is up happening as
Bruce kind of passes out and then has
this sort of vision to this recollection
back to you know really like a dream of
sorts it seems to when he was younger he
was playing on like a little
merry-go-round and then suddenly out of
like the back of a tree he sees this
like horrific looking woman that
literally looks like enchantress like
The Enchantress demon and starts talking
to him and basically saying like I
existed before everything and I'll exist
after everything but I have a secret to
tell you
I have something that you need to know
kind of playing mind games with him so
the idea of him being like early
experiencing demons when he was younger
being possessed something along those
lines is actually pretty awesome there's
over here it basically picks up with him
kind of meeting with Constantine and
Constantine going on and talking about a
few things but it's somewhat cool
because they talk about how there was a
body quote/unquote discovered in Gotham
River but the body is John Doe he hasn't
been identified yet at the outset they
basically say like it's the body of the
Joker
you know the Joker's been family there's
also be reference to another body later
on but Constantine is joined by dead man
now those guys who don't know Boston
brand Boston brands kind of weird you
know when it comes to his role as dead
man Boston brand was originally a guy
who was murdered and his role is to
search throughout the world looking for
his killer uh which I don't think ever
ever happened his the reason why he
still haunts the world but he can like
take over bodies different things like
that you know inhabit and have it this
the bodies of living beings and so on
and then interact with various people
it's kind of weird I want to say that
there was a point in DC comics where you
had Hawk and Dove who were who were
lovers I think like Hawk died or
something like that and then like became
the new dead man and then inhabited the
body of somebody else and then actually
tried to like get it on with Duff it was
I can remember it was it was something
weird like it's weird I'm not really
familiar with their history so don't
hold me to that and if you're more
familiar post in the comments let me
know let me know how that really went
but the other half of this is it also
switches over to Thomas Wayne and this
is kind of an interesting situation
because the way this seems to hint is
that Thomas Wayne was approaching like
prostitutes or something like that like
yeah he's got Bruce with him and the
woman saying things like well if you
want to spend time with me you have to
get rid of you have to leave your son or
something along those lines and his
response is well my son with you know
goes with me everywhere I go and that
kind of a thing but Bruce starts leaning
over the edge of this bridge and almost
falls to his death and so it's kind of
interesting because it's like one of
these
things where if I were a betting man I
would argue the idea here was to say
well it's Bruce Wayne overcoming his
fears essentially like Bruce Wayne faces
death in the face all the time he looks
death in the face all the time and it's
just one of those things that he always
did he always in doors that he always
deals with it's the nature of what it
means to be his character and so from
here it picks up with Commissioner
Gordon talking to basically like a
vagrant
it would seem about some crime that had
recently taken place but the vigor is
kind of losing his mind rambling on
about how like it was the devil who did
it you know that it was it was a monster
of sorts in you know that that committed
this heinous act and you know this
homeless guy saw everything unfolds and
all I kind of good stuff this is where
Brian Azzarello really shines because
what happens is you have Constantine
basically narrating this whole thing and
Constantine begins to ask the question
of what's the point of Gotham City like
what's the point of Batman this God even
really exists and that's why these
things are kind of cool is because when
you look at Gotham by and large it's
like the worst place to be save maybe
like Bludhaven blend hit it might be a
little bit worse mostly because there's
never been a Batman there like II that
Nightwing there and that was trying to
clean it up right now but like awesome
city is terrible like people die every
day for like any number of different
things so I'm like robberies gone wrong
too like the fact that somebody hates
somebody else like gang rivalries all
kinds of different things and so it's
the question of what's actually going on
and so you end up having like Batman who
jumps in and chases down this vagrant
but again Constantine narrates this
whole thing and talked about how like it
may be that God's insane that the only
sane being among all the angels and
devils is like the devil himself that
like gods insane like the angels are
nuts is this notion that like God lost
its mind with creation is it's one of
these situations where Constantine kind
of pitches this idea that if there is a
God out there then he's flying by the
seat of his pants just like everybody
else and so and so all you can really do
is just make your way in the world
that's it you know invoking things like
mysterious ways and so on it's just
humanity's way of trying to understand
why God doesn't actually do anything
it's one of these cool scenarios and
these cool explanations so where Batman
chases down this vagrant who basically
hops a fence and then runs into an
alleyway the response to Batman is I
know what you did and so it was kind of
cool here because then you get to like
one of the one of the big moments you
know of course one of the big things
where you kind of see Batman's penis and
like you have a you have him in the
Batcave and basically running like a
body scan on himself to see what kind of
damage he might have lacerations cuts
different things like that and then he
starts to chime in on the bodies of the
john doe's and you of course the Joker
being one of those the computer scanning
the medical databases says none of those
IDs are known because of course we don't
know the idea of the Joker whether the
location of the Joker's body is unknown
and that is that it's not in the
hospital which begs the question where
in the heck is it and so that's why
things get kind of bonkers because from
there you have Batman who's almost kind
of like tormented by the Batman concept
because when he starts going through he
starts hearing a voice in his head that
says well maybe check your head you know
and then he sees of course he looks
around he sees Batman he's terrified of
it and falls to the ground and so the
idea seems to be here that like Batman
killed the Joker like that seems to be
the notion of what's being hid out here
is like the Joker's dead because of
Batman because of what Bruce Wayne did
and so that's why things get kind of
bonkers because from there he actually
goes back out into the street again to
find out what's going on with the Joker
himself why he's not in the hospital and
so visiting various people you know
going in and kind of spinning Tom and it
looks like he's got his patches Malone
identity on or at least that kind of
seems to be the case I mean he's really
more of just like a vagrant you know
dressed as a vagrant at this point but
there's actually Zatanna which is kind
of cool and it's a whole different take
on her character instead of her being
like this magician who puts on like
magic shows for the enjoyment of the
public in order to you know to give them
what they want which is to say the
belief that magic doesn't exist when it
actually does instead she's basically
just like a like doing parlor tricks you
know doing card tricks and so on and so
forth and hustling people out of their
money
it's basically what it is like cetana
became a hustler which is kind of
interesting but then Boston brand
reappears and starts jumping from body
to body warning Batman there's a
conspiracy against you there are people
out there that are hunting you down that
are trying to find you and that are
trying to commit particular acts against
you now none of that stuff is really
expanded on by him none of it really
goes anywhere and that's a crazy thing
about about Boston brands and he doesn't
actually reveal any information to Bruce
he just kind of says there's a thing
going on but notice that what you end up
having is Bruce Wayne basically being
like invoking all these different
magical entities these angels demons and
so on and so forth which kind of makes
sense I mean he's like the devil of
Gotham and so when you're talking about
a guy like that you know the demon of
Gotham City it makes sense that like
even if I'm only on a metaphorical level
he kind of belongs to that part of DC
Comics and so where he approaches its
khana and says look there's a guy that
I'm looking for have you seen him at all
she flips over a card and says you're
looking for the Joker as that's why it
gets kind of bonkers because you
basically have this this whole thing
where like he had kind of has like a
flashback to himself as a kid and that's
when you end up realizing it's not
really a dream of something that didn't
happen it's a dream of something that
did and like when he has this dream when
he's wearing these when he's in his bed
you know I'm kind of having this
flashback and he looks over into the
corner that demon is more or less
sitting there and basically says like I
have things to show you I
things that you need to see I have
things that are important like I can
show you how not to be afraid and so as
it's almost as though like Batman gave
him to like the devil gave into like the
inner demons of himself in order to
become the person that he was it's kind
of twisted but again the hunt is on for
the Joker and so where the the question
is you know where Batman yoga basically
means John Constantine in the church and
Constantine you know is they were the
two of them are having a having a
conversation Batman says like the Joker
still seems to be alive and
Constantine's responses know that Joker
should be dead but I don't think he is
and when the question is asked why we
end up basically looking up to Jesus on
a cross with him with his face painted
to look like the Joker his hair painted
green hahaha
written all over the cross all over
Joker and all around the entire scene
but it really seems to toy with this
idea of like angels and demons that like
Batman is almost like the Angel of Death
for the various criminals who were out
there and the Joker is by definition his
arch-nemesis you know this kind of
eternal demon this eternal force kind of
playing a little bit on what it was that
Scott Snyder did in the new 52 when it
was the idea of Joker being the pale man
and having been alive for like hundreds
of years just by consuming Dionysian and
always creating like these these acts of
chaos he's actually destruction and so
on but again it's really interesting and
that's the nature of Brian Brian
Azzarello writing you don't really know
what it is until you get to the
conclusion until you finish it up until
that point it's just a lot of mystery
and a lot of intrigue it's like a much
smaller version of like Jonathan
Hickman's writing or something like that
but it is cool and I'm very excited to
see what happens next but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you